hello my name is Kathy I my tenure track
investigator at the National Institute
at NIH and I want to thank them all for
this invitation to talk about some of
her ongoing work to develop an
autologous IPS cell based therapy for
macular degeneration so it just to get
everyone oriented going to be talking
about
of the eye
so this slide shows you the homeostatic
unit in the back of the eye the retina
on top the photoreceptors and in between
the photoreceptors and the blood supply
is languished a layer called the retinal
pigment epithelium but most of the
diseases that affect the back of the eye
it's the submitted unit that is affected
during the disease process so if we take
a closer look at the silver static unit
see that RP is really strategically
located between before receptor cells
and the blood supply and if you can see
in this slide at RP cells are highly
polarized they have different structures
with apical side and laser sight on the
base of sight RP cells sit on a
pernicious Crookes membrane and on the
apical side they have this apical
processes that interact with the photo
several other segments and I look like
to call them the business end of our T
cells and by and the polarized structure
of these are T cells is maintained by
this time changes between neighboring
cells with by doing this RP cells of a
mediates metabolic transport from the
blood to further site for receptors and
backwards and it also helps maintain
four receptor health and integrity
throughout its life by it almost these
functions that are listed on this slide
so you can imagine something like this
that is so critical for four receptor
survival and the health if our T cells
are damaged it leads to disease onset
and and sometimes in severe cases
blindness and the next slide shows an
example of they were seeing the beasts
age-related macular degeneration nd that
is caused by damage of our T cells in
the back of the eye
hey you see on one panel how are normal
people with normal vision see and on the
other panel you see patients with an AMD
vision they are blinding the central
policy vision that means F anyway they
look in the central part that I they
won't be able to see the disease affects
more than 30 million people worldwide
and currently and is for the drive form
of this disease
there is no cure
so when we look at the back of the eye
of any patients this is what you see as
how the disease work on the top panel
shows you a red normal healthy retina
the rectum pigment epithelium and the
chloride binding patients with the dry
form of disease see that the
photoreceptors are damaged are dead and
so is the RP and the corrado blood
supply on this second part is where the
patient's vision is gone completely with
their no cells left but then going from
the central part towards the RPE this is
area called the transition zone where
photoreceptors are still surviving and
RV's is gone
so that suggests that it is for the
septal area in the verge of time is
suggesting that RP dies first in AMD and
similarly leading also to coated
capillaries are my lab works on various
aspects of these disease initiation how
these RP cells start to become
dysfunction of the disease progresses as
a cells start to die and also all the
treatments are both small water filter
band emcell therapy treatment treatments
that are referring to develop for this
disease another advantage of this
disease is wet AMD in which the kuru
capillaries that hyper proliferate and
they penetrate through the artery
leaking fluid and blood into the are
pianning to the retina again leading to
blindness
what we do here at nei is use 2d and 3d
models direct from IPS cells to both
recreate disease in a dish and to also
treat patients or to develop cell
therapies to treat these patients who
have this blinding disease and I'll walk
you through some of our ongoing work
so just going to recap my lab we'll
start with patient cells patient on
halide owners big IPS cell from the
somatic tissue in Part B cells and use
these RP cells to develop either 2d or
3d disease models for drug screens they
call it disease in addition approach
movies study disease pathways to path
analysis and identifying discover new
drugs and hope to bring those to expect
the patient and in the same time we use
our T cells to develop an RPD patch that
we're bringing back to patients as a
cell therapy
first things first how do we make these
cells from IPS cell so the top panel
here in this slide shows you a pathway
how are B cells mature B cells are made
from IPS cells and really for for a
process that we want to work very
efficiently because if we want to
develop a cell therapy or disease models
we really optimize how these cells are
made and a very high efficiency and
realistically
to really functional in which your state
and this was really guided by
developmental biology of our B cells
making them go through various stages of
our video loop and new actor term are
the progenitor all the way to mature are
we using just combination of different
growth factors a different kind point
the bottom panel shows you that the
protocol really works well you see a
dish full of pigmented homogeneously
pigmented RPE cells confidently present
in the dish the middle panel shows you a
flow plot that's looking at one of the
RV markers showing you more than 98%
pure homogeneous population of arcing
cells a very high expression of our
being marker and then it also shows you
how to proceed all is this process we've
done it over thirty four different known
as both helding illness disease donors
and in every single case we can make our
T cells at a very high efficiency in
this protocol now the next panel shows
you the next slide shows you a molar
layer of art be really polarized monitor
of our T in this case made on a PhD
scaffold this comes later the second
half of my talk and we're using this
variable scaffold to transplant RB patch
in patient but this slide really
illustrate by a deputy by scanning am
how polarized how homogeneously
polarized this model layer is and blue
you see the careful that is considered
colored in brown other cells you're
looking at it from a side angle you see
three cells but the nuclei here but most
interesting is is green structure these
are these remember the business center
part of yourself the apical processes
and I hope you can appreciate that plug
the patch is very homogeneous ly
polarized tissue is present and then
if we again trying to develop the
disease models that really replicate
patient's disease and also trying to
double cell therapy we need to make sure
that the cells are functional and
behaved like native a few cells and when
I show you just one example that I just
regard we do display all the features of
native RPE cells in this case we're
measuring electrical response of RPE
cells and this just one actually shows
you so many different genes and pathways
are working correctly in these cells
most of this data has been published and
view that in a prius publication but
what it shows you is that transept the
tiller is this is really a function of
the tight junctions through neighboring
cells that I mentioned in my
introduction are correctly formed cells
have presented resistance to the flow of
crime trans applicated the potential
excuse me
of of the cells difference between
apical embezzlement arresting pinches
showing how polarized they are about 4
millivolts here is again similar to
Native art B cells and then the ability
of cells to respond to exothermic use
which has reduced apical potassium
concentration something that happens
when light hits the eye or application
of ATP that causes depolarization pulse
leading to calcium or release in cells
and activation of chloride channels all
of those asses all of those functions
are intact in IPS around Rp cells and
they behave almost identical to native
cells so suggesting that these cells
what we have made in a dish are really
to be used up now the other cell type
that I want to introduce before we get
on with our 3d disease modeling as an
appeal yourself again made with a
similar to a currently guided process
from IPS cells a much shorter protocol
then our V cannot be between our two
cells would take about ten weeks within
this case we can make an appeal in cells
in about two weeks
bhana panel shows you standing for city
31 here present here on this cells and
again by flow more than 97% cure and
appeals
also a protocol very reproducible
they've done now over actually ten
different donors both healthy in disease
and we can always make and it's kill
cells that are very high efficient
so then when we do is to combine RB and
endothelial cells into 3d disease model
we use a technique culturally
bioprinting what it does is on top you
see a 3d bioprinter which has true to
print heads to needle that move in a
very precise XYZ orientation that you
can control and we fill this up with
something which we called bio ink which
contains the endothelial cells images I
just showed you
parasites fiberglass and hydrogel that
you can see the bottom panel now it's
printing the needle head is printing a
zig-zag pattern in this case and we can
print any pattern we like but this
zigzag pattern allows us to make bigger
vessels in the area that is printed and
the empty area that you see in between
is that where angiogenesis happens and
so we can quantify how much angiogenesis
happen from this and reticular stuff so
the way this process works is we start
off with a biodegradable scaffold that I
showed you previously we know png-8
electrospray and nano fibers of tea and
you know scandium shows you how the
network of fibers allows cells to grow
on top of it
so take the scaffold flip it in one of
the direction and we buy a printed
bio-ink on top just like I just showed
you flip it upside down stick it out
these cells on on the other side and let
it mature for about four to six weeks
and the scaffold degrades its replaced
by ECM that is made both by RPE cells
and by the endothelial cells and
fiberglass on the other side and it
becomes came too similar to books
membrane that is naturally present
between RP and endothelial cells or LPN
career capillaries in the eye and about
four to five weeks the tissues start to
look really like this this is one
example of a 3d bioprinting tissue you
have Carvey on top and in between the
scaffold has been replaced by ECM and on
the bottom you see capillaries here
labeled in green final filled cells and
in red for parasites and you'll see a
dense capillary network throughout the
bottom panel very similar to the choroid
next lectures your movie in which
disease can be running to the correct
side of a delicacy
of various sides of Newman from 20 to 50
micron running to the entire tissue game
labeled in green for endothelial cells
and red for parasites
the tissue combined together looks
similar to this is the art beam on their
side on the left label here for Excel
process marker is ring in green that
shows you how polarized cells are and
ecad ring in red which labels the tight
junctions between neighboring cells
showing you that cells are conflict and
and electrically tight and then on the
bottom panel you see a vascular network
here labeled very dense muscular Network
labeled here with the fenestration
marker PL VAP so that is the physician
marker spinning with interesting that
goddess thinking what whether these
vessels actually are fenestrated
so for those of you who don't think
organist raishin every day and this is a
in capillaries is a small hole in the
plasma membrane of endothelium cells
about seventy to hundred micron sized
pores that allow easy flow of
macromolecules
and it's a fin it's a hallmark feature
of fertile vessels but also cleaning the
vessels throughout the body so we
compare how rattles look like to
published literature you can see the
left panel here published fetal human
chloride because it's fenestrations
and in the membrane of endocrine cells
and if you compare that to what we see
in the in our less cells sprinkle it
from my PSV you can see similar pattern
of fenestration throughout the
endothelial membrane
it's not really opens up a new field and
topic for us you know what really causes
when a session former formation in the
cells and we know that these
fenestrations are dependent on our beam
on layer but what causes them what
molecules are required what signaling
pathways are required to to make
fenestrations and what causes of an
efficient loss in diseases like entity
so now moving on with with really pretty
disease modeling using this tissue I
want to show you the first example of
the 3d tissues where we have such a wild
type RPE and once endothelial cells so
here on top you will see is Alena
meaning green and elliptic and in-cabin
inbred around the self and as they play
the video you will see the vessels at
the bottom again labeled in green and
red they get only one and PL VAP so that
we could lose in the ring from top to
bottom using chemistry at the vascular
Network coming back up let's glue
Network again and then the RP cells so
what we're trying to do here to really
understand and learn more about the
tissue we're doing with the color depth
scan in which we see what and the right
sign is a scale of the depth scanner the
vessels are green they're the colloidal
interface if they're yellow
they are the Brooks membrane are the
interface and if they are red then
they're about the above the RPE so in
this case if I get back to that point
again you'll see most of the restaurants
are green but if you yellow and there's
no red metal
now if you contrast that to what I'm
going to show you the next slide where
we made a tissue in which we or
expressed transcription factor step 3
only in RPE cells and we know that leads
to increase expression of Reggie F and
il-6 and by our B cells and want to see
the consequences of that on the choroid
so really pay attention to the rescuer
network here you see in - she goes up
and down
dense Network but when we see the do the
depths can you will see how the picture
looks different from the wild-type
tissue here instead of floral clean
vessels we have a lot of yellow vessels
I think they are all on a poster books
membrane if you pay attention to this
white circle actually just moved so
right next to the white circle you see
the right next to this white circle you
will see there's one restaurant that
goes all the way across from the Arctic
from the coal right through the Brooks
membrane all the way into the RP so
really just like as I shouldn't top
panel here it would happen saying that
Andy that one of the vessel has
penny
to the RV on the other side so it's
really the model that have been able to
create object AMD in a dish now I'll
switch to another model which is the
other kind of advanced AMD the dry and B
in this case similar tissue but we have
stressed it with a complement stress
that which has been showed variously can
use to sunlight deposited formation in a
dish and I hope you can already
appreciate that the RPE looks pretty
sick on top of this tissue now when I
play you will see the vessels at the
bottom in red again and April II is the
hallmark feature of cruise and deposit
is is labeled in magenta color so
Genesis RPGs on top and you can see a
blue deposits turning around you can see
the vascular network is really sparse
here as a base as compared to the wild
type or the red and the tissue looks
like the vessels are aggressing and
dying off and again as a teacher comes
that you can see this dense April
redeposit now again highlighted by these
two circles you'll see a large one
fairly large a pretty positive and one
it kind of a condensation of many
deposits actually this one is almost of
the order of 100 20 40 micron various of
the size that is thought to be the
stageman and the disease turns into an
advanced stage so really buy it buy both
copies just an example of that I'm
making dry and wet in dear models using
a 3d tissue but then at the same time we
can use this technology to also discover
diseases that can help undo your rescue
some of these cellular and the
phenotypes so this is the CM shows you
that is a pre deposits on the reels they
are similar to the basil deposits
basolateral deposits or basal lamina
deposits seen on the basal side of RPE
cells currently we are actually running
a crisper cast lines you know my crystal
castle on screen to identify to discover
genes that are responsible for the
student formation so we did
venez a drug screen for prosthetic drugs
that would actually rescue our ee cells
based on the prosthetic stressor and
identify three drugs and ask if these
three drugs that can rescue our B cell
that could they also rescue formation of
April redeposit and one of the drug this
is I think glute wrote here can actually
significantly reduce the amount of input
that forms in this complement stress
person rule would be controlled tissue
and in orange is the complement stress
tissue which has a significantly higher
number of April redeposits over the
tissue but when we treat this same
tissue with the drug as we stress it we
see that number of April positive
deposits are significantly reduced
almost back to the control levels so
we're very excited about this because
this is a I think the first example of a
drug that can reduce the formation of a
political and so potentially could
reduce the formation of grooves and
deposits or perhaps it can be translated
all the way to patients
that's the first part of my talk showing
you little ization of 2d and 3d models
models to do to both understand disease
and out these pathways in a dish but
also to do drug testing into a discovery
which can be potentially for potentially
novel drugs but then this now in the
second part of my talk I wanna switch
gears and talk about cell based therapy
are we using this approach to develop a
cell therapy for any patient
back to the slide that I showed you
previously about this transition zone
where the photoreceptors are still
surviving but the RP is gone the idea
people had for a long time was to
transplant and RP implant here in the
transition zone and rescue the overlying
for receptors from dying and in fact it
has been surgically tried with people of
cut out a piece of RB from the periphery
of the same eye translocated it into the
macula and grafted it and in a small
number of patient where this graph has
survived and implanted and engrafted
this they saw that patient's vision was
stable stable for you just to come in
the for acceptors over the area of the
implant work or rescued and that is
indeed for us the guiding principle for
our trance our our process to develop a
Natalia cell therapy rather than cutting
it out from the periphery of the same
eye we want to make it from IPS cells
off the same patients blood drive from
st. patients blood so the next slide
shows you how we converted our research
game infection process into a gene tigre
manufacturing process the draw starting
with draw blood and base you isolating
cd34 positive cells
reprogramming them into IPS cells we
nail down or we note it down every
single day how different processes were
going to be done the SOPs would have
looked to making the bank to
characterizing the bank and then from
there setting up the sensation of 3 or
50 clones in parallel going all the way
to progenitor stage and then seeding the
cells onto the PSG attach like I showed
you previously so this process takes
about six weeks six months excuse me
but we have been able to map out every
single day of this process where it's
going to be done how life is also going
to make characterize our T cells are
going to be made when the QC is going to
be done and what the QC parameters are
going to be to really have a go/no-go
point as many as moving forward towards
clicker cell therapy or clinical
translation of this product at the same
time we have
here on the right you see some
intermediate stages where we covered
some overt issue ourselves so that in
case the process fails we can get back
to one of these intermediate stages and
got again so the process again in
clinical grade setting works really
really reasonably in Buckley this is an
example of a scale out and a sensation
on purification of this process but
we've done here is 107 different
different differentiation run across 28
different IPS cell lines performed by 12
from 12 different owners performer four
different operators and black is see
what was a purity of cells before we
have enrichment steps at the day four
years before the enrichment step and we
range somewhere from 90% to I think
almost forty fifty percent but after the
enrichment step we go all the way to
almost 99% purity in pretty much every
single case and I should say that more
than 80 percent the IPS LS we tested
were successful in this process and 100
percent the donors that we have saved
resulted in successful art with the
transition so we are fairly confident
that as we move into the clinic we will
be able to make robust our free cells
from every single patient that we enroll
in our clinical trial
now another important feature as as we
are making cells for transplantation in
patients is how do we how do we qualify
this the cells of good that they are
ready for transplantation
so to do that what we did is we
developed a new network that would allow
us to predict transplantable
heartbeat product so the way this works
is that we use which is what is called
quantitative bright field microscopy and
in this case we take images of cells as
it as they were differentiating and we
develop in your network that would
analyze those images and compare that to
the end result which is a again the
resistance of cells as epithelial
systems of the molar layer and come and
use that as a learning set but then it
after the network has been trained we
can use a network to now start making
predictions using a new sample so the
network will be able to predict which
don't know the cells came from and what
was the TR what will be the T are called
the mono layer this was one way of doing
it and the second way was and while we
were training the network we also
segmented borders of cells by just a
simple and a membrane stain and often
which was hand corrected afterwards to
make sure that the network does
recognize all the cell borders so we
retrain the network on n corrected cells
and then extract it all the cellular
features for examples that Aelia
hexagonal any number of neighbors and
then use those cellular features to
again predict the same outcome can we
have the silver features correlate to
cleanse a potato resistance or donor
identity of the cells so this seems to
be working well I will show you want to
data point for this again you have
already seen what we did at the neural
network in which we train the network
for RP images and ter and asked it to
predict the function of cells after it
was trained it's an example of one
dataset paper measuring TransAfrica
resistance of three different types of
cells in blue would be cells that are
not mature at all we call them feel like
they chemically kept on mature in green
would be cells that have been partially
matured and in red would be done set up
in fully mature again chemically and the
threshold for TR in this case is 400
ohms per square centimetre and the
x-axis
the measure ter that we experimental e
measure on this smaller layer excuse me
and on the y-axis is the tia that is
predicted by our network so first thing
that you notice is that the network is
almost linearly working similar to our
experimental setup that it can work the
same way of both the network and
measurement collinear to each other that
means they have similar result and
second is again the network is able to
tell us differences between less mature
selves to really mature cells to fully
mature cells so I think this could be
really a way of validating and
characterizing our scaffold of a patch
our key patch before transplanting it
into patients and really figuring out if
the patch was masked one table or not
because it's a relatively this
pathetically easy test to run and the
genes in facility
we can make cells robustly and
characterize them we want to make sure
that these cells are safe before we
transplant them into patients so we
perform preclinical animal studies to
test both safety and efficacy of our
company patch
first we tested whether else would lead
to an in tumor or tumor tumor or
toxicity in the eye and you know that's
one of the really biggest challenge with
any stem cell therapy that water use
that if there is temps are left in the
final product they could lead to tumor
or teratoma formation it is an example
of actually pure IPS cells and checked
in the subretinal space leading to this
massive teratoma pushing the lens out
and you can see all three germ layers
identified in the third column but in
contrast when we transplant and IPL ugly
patch it just completely integrates in
at the back of the eye double lead to
any tumor or teratoma formation this red
cells are staying for stem 121 which of
the human marker and as you notice here
you don't see the scaffold anymore
because it's 10 weeks past
transplantation the scaffold is degraded
and the human ugly patch has completely
integrated into the back of the red eye
in this case to test the efficacy of
this patch we then looked at models in
pigs in which we wanted to see this
efficacy of the entire four by two
millimeter patch that we intend to
transplant in patients but as you know
may know that in pigs is no genetic
model for AMD so we developed laser
induced are the ablation model in pigs
we use a micro pulse laser that uses 532
nanometer wavelength to selectively
oblique RP cells because that wavelength
is absorbed by the pigment of RP the
heat up and birth and as the RP cells
would die photoreceptors would start to
die because they're functional their
their metabolic support is missing and
and that's what you see in the bottom
panel here infrared image of four pig
funders be a seven by four millimeter
what we call a value defect where RP
cells are missing because nothing for
red light passes through and you see
that's why is the lighter color and it's
also confirmed by histology seabrooke's
membrane that is the dark RPE cells and
also comes up RP cells that are just
sitting there as a result for receptors
are starting to tie the other segments
are much shorter and then they should be
so the goal would be to transplant and
RP pads right here and how we protect
the photo status above the area of the
transplant so keep in mind that in we're
transplanting human RP patch and a pig
eye and asking you to protect pit
photoreceptors from dying to develop a
tool to bring the patch to the back of
the eye this is tool has a tip curvature
that fixed the back of the eye
it takes the scaffold the pads only in
one orientation it's made such that
surgeon could see the patch while he's
delivering it to the back of the eye and
it's controlled by a foot panel the next
lectures your video of the surgery the
as you can see the pig eyes eye has
already been prepped surgeons making the
incision in the eye wall a little bigger
to put the patch tool inside the eye and
his next shot you will see the tool is a
tip of the tool is a patch RV pad you
can see pigmented cells on top surgeon
is aligning it with a cut under the
retina and the retina has already been
lifted and the patch will be delivering
under the retina and the retina would be
flattened on top of the patch so it
stays there which we can confirm by a
technique called Oct article corn and
tomography where we can see the back of
the eye by a reflectance coming from the
from the back of the eye pea and fast
Mew we see the patch here and by side
view this yellow line shows you
videography patches and you can see the
redness fairly healthy about the area of
the patch now to really measure function
optimal function advocacy off the patch
we use a technique called multifocal ERG
basically we're measuring electrical
responses from the back of the eye from
the retina by shining multiple different
light pulses whenever the light will hit
we'll get an electrical response from
that part of the right now then since it
the light hits the healthy part of the
retina we get a response nice and big
and robust response but if the light
hits the laser injured pathway we did
not do as a patch we get minimal almost
no response and that would be like
somewhere here in the eye but if the
light hits the time
landing pad which would be right above
this yellow line we get a response that
is in between the healthy part and the
injured part suggesting that the human
Agra patch is able to protect the
pigfoot receptors to some extent and
protect the retina actually functionally
from time
and we can also collaborate these
findings - ecology the next slide shows
you say my two differ areas lizard area
with no transplant and lizard it yogic
transplant
you can see the transplant here marked
with the yellow line you can see this
human nuclei labeled here pigmented
cells notice the thickness difference
the thickness of the other nuclear layer
the nuclear awful receptors above the
area of the transplant it's almost
double from the excavated area where
there was no transplant suggesting that
human cells are able to protect Pig full
receptors from dying and pick out a
neutral layer from from getting smaller
we can also show functional integration
of the patch this is kind of a 3d
rendering off the part of the eye part
of the retina in red is a gained human
cells labeled with stem 121 and in green
we have labels rhodopsins figured off
him and you can see that rhodopsin as
being signal is also can be seen inside
human cells suggesting that human cells
have taken up phagocytose to pick up a
segment so it's a typical feature
function of our b cells showing you that
human cells that actually functionally
integrated in the back of the pig eye
all of this work is summarized and then
led to an IND we what I showed you is
that we performed clinical grade
manufacturing of the patch I didn't get
to show you that we actually validated
this data from three cloves per patient
and perform functional validation of the
patch I showed you some of the products
values that led to testing the safety of
the patch in animal in in rats and in
pigs and also the functional studies
that that led to GOP function studies in
pigs all of this work has been completed
and when the process of putting together
the IND to be somebody hopefully in a
couple of months to start the clinical
trial right after that so with that I
want to thank the entire team here which
you see is the cell therapy team that
actually last year got an award from the
NIH director for their efforts to
develop a cell therapy product and then
here is a 3d bioprinting team some of
the members from the team Russ angie
fuji and grow
some of these people have been working
on a three-bar pending contact
oh so that thank you very much